[Music]
hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here on the frontline at San
Diego comic-con 2014 I have found a very
cool miniature studio over here I'm
standing with my new friend Dylan Dylan
what do you do I'm an animator on Robot
Chicken 4 which is produced at stupid
buddy studios and right now I'm
animating some shots just for comic-con
just doing a little demo of what it's
like to animate on Robot Chicken and how
we do it I noticed right away that
you've got a very special power glove
here what's going on there I I'm odd if
I diss power glove to be a Bluetooth
controller for dragons stop motion
dragon frame stop motion which we use to
animate the program which we used to
animate Robot Chicken and I've been
using this for a couple of years I wear
a power glove to work it's pretty it's
pretty awesome I you know I love the
power glove it's so bad and all that not
many people can say that they wear a
power glove to work or that it helps
them do their daily job yeah I think
I've been using it for about two years
so I think I probably have used it more
than anyone is ever in the 25 years of
the power glove I've probably used it
more than anyone very cool so tell me
you know you told us on a large level
what it is you're doing with the glove
but can you explain for someone who
might not be too familiar with animation
what exactly are you controlling with
these buttons well so with the with the
number pad here I I set it to to switch
me back and forth between my my
individual frames so that I can track
the motion of the characters so that's
how we that's how we know like when
we've moved the character enough or when
we haven't moved it and not you know
when we need to move it more we you know
we so I basically set it up as a
Bluetooth keyboard so that it I set all
the hot keys to control the different
components of the program you know that
is the coolest Bluetooth keyboard I have
ever seen officially what kind of films
are you making here what's going on in
this scene right now
right now I've got all
Clint Eastwood being beat up by young
Clint Eastwood why is that happening
well I figured I might as well pit them
against each other and see who comes out
on top I think I think my money's on old
Clint Eastwood because he's got some
young in Clint Eastwood in him so he I
think he's probably he knows his moves
and all he'll probably he'll probably
win an epic battle indeed well could you
show us a little bit of the animation
process like what each frame looks like
yeah so right now so old Clint Eastwood
is coming up and I'm gonna give him a
little bit more right just like this and
then I'm going to check to see if I did
that right yeah it looks right yeah and
then this Queen Eastwood's gonna
stabilize out and then yeah and we'll
take the frame there I love you've got
the little frowny mouth on ya that's
like it's like gritting teeth mouth you
know are those mouths little stickers I
see here yeah they are there we use
little stickers I also added this little
retractable tweezers so that I could
take sticker mouths off and put them put
them on the characters like I would
probably put it on
and then he's now he's got yeah so yeah
he did now he's got a little mouth on it
such expression for sure thank you so
much this has been very educational and
I love the inspiration of using a game
controller that may not have been so
useful in its day for something that is
much more useful now it's important to
improve upon the past - exactly exactly
well let me know what you think of that
modded power glove I'm certainly
impressed are you tweet at me at Ana
professor and let me know